this next speaker is actually one of my
team members and I found him on Twitter
and he just recently had his one year
anniversary in my company aside from
being an awesome member of our team
um he has only been shot at once
and blown up twice
despite rumors to the contrary there's
been a lot more everyone please welcome
Nick
he's right about hiring people Jared's a
great guy to work for the only problem
is he'll take a lot of the work you do
and put it in one of his slide decks and
take credit for it
so I did want to mention to you and he
did miss out on Snick and Snick is a
really nice plug-in for Docker whenever
you're building Docker containers and
stuff from the image itself it'll
automatically scan everything for you
and kick out the cves that it violates
it's a pretty cool tool I like to use it
myself
so anything I talk about here today is
for educational purposes only
um
don't break things you're not allowed to
break there's a there's a code with
ethical hacking it's fine if you break
it but if you have permission that's
terrific you just tell them how to fix
it after you break it if you do not have
permission congratulations you get to
spend time in the federal pen so just
letting you know this stuff is for
educational purposes only
and uh I enjoy speaking in public but I
have a really difficult time not cussing
so I apologize that's the aircraft
mechanic in me if I do I want to hear a
boo like let's do it right now everybody
move come on okay so if I cuss you do
that you call me out and I'll keep going
I'll have to live with it
so uh the reason why I put this up there
is I had to take several hours and
compress it to 20 minutes
and so I have this talk I know you're
not supposed to click on strange links
from strangers but if you want you can
run that through virus toll first if you
like all it is is my GitHub with a PDF
of this talk all the links are there and
I just say if you guys want to go deeper
in it because I want you to I want to
pull you guys into cyber security I
think we need more analytic people in
cyber security and that's the whole
point of this
so that's what we start out with
everything is hacked
I could yell we're all going to die but
it you know it makes its point right
there
so who am I uh box swapper you can find
me on Twitter also I just put this talk
it's pinned up there if you want it
um I'm an ethical hacker Defcon 29
speaker and uh so I'm used to a lot of
interactions in hacking conferences when
you speak people interrupt you when
you're wrong they prove you wrong uh
we're supposed to take several shots
before we talk for the first time but
I'm not going to do that here because I
want to stay coherent but if you
interrupt me or if you have any
questions or if I talk too fast because
I'm excited say hey Nick mixed up and I
will go over whatever you want me to go
over I have no issue with that and we
all learned something from it I get to
learn my audience better because this is
my first time talking to y'all
so uh I'm an aeronautical pin tester
that came from being an aircraft
mechanic if I came into cyber security
um I hacked aircraft uh cispy testing
hopeful yeah I failed it I'll admit I
failed it 50 pass rate on that test it's
a tough one I think I did pretty well
but next time I can knock it out of the
park I do like to watch CDE and nvds you
know how a lot of people watch YouTube
I'd sit and watch the threads as they
come out it's enjoyable to me see what's
coming out see what's broken I call
myself a server mechanic I'm still
asking for Jared to give me that on my
uh my card so I can pass out to everyone
I will take that title gladly and just
recently I became a kubernetes Wrangler
and if you've ever had to deal with
kubernetes I'm more than happy to call
myself a Wrangler especially since I
like to call Rancher one of the things
to use to adjust it
so if you want to see my talk I talk
about hacking aircraft that link will be
right there for you and this is my first
markdown slide deck so it's gonna get
weird
so uh well I want to go over the
reported Trends the way you can find
these reports the way you can go over
this stuff yourself when you need to and
the vulnerabilities that come up because
Mega corporations got a court they they
do what they do we all understand it's
that bottom line uh it's getting to the
point now where it's becoming more and
more dangerous as more and more of Our
Lives become online and uh we just got
to watch out for some of their practices
I'll show you guys a few toys to break
the world
this is the demo part
yeah yeah I didn't sacrifice any chicken
so it's probably not going to work
and then I want to go over the
corrective actions ways that you can
defend yourself and help yourself in
your own life and then I wanted to
introduce you all to Rita and I'll
explain it more when we get there
so we'll go over some basic definitions
because you're going to hear these in
the future what is a hack the best way
in all of these uh all of the cdes
everything they always follow by the
same thing the CIA Trad not that CA not
that Triad but it's the confidentiality
integrity and availability if any of
those are compromised that's considered
a hack you're done Adidas you know the
distributed denial of service attack
that would be a hack because now you
lost availability just an example
uh so there's something in the hacker
Community nobody wants to be called a
skid or a Skitty it's basically a script
hitting a person who uses a scripts to
attack a vulnerability they are not
talented they just find the stuff online
pull it down and they just run it and
see what happens it can get you in a lot
of trouble especially if you don't know
what you're doing especially with some
of the tools I'm about to show you so
what is the vulnerability because I'll
be spot talking about that basic a
weakness in a system that can be
exploited
so these are the reported Trends these
are the links I wanted to tell you about
the uh the Verizon data breach
investigation report it is like the
Touchstone for a lot of uh blue teamers
whenever we have to present to our
bosses hey this is the cyber security
posture we need to take this what we
need to defend against this is where
everybody goes uh it's written by uh one
of the data analytic nerds that you all
know that I just got to meet uh Bob
rudis
and it's a beautiful product it's one of
my favorites we always use that to to
explain what's going on the meter cves
common vulnerabilities and exposures a
lot of the vulnerability scanners are
based off of these word lists you can
download a Json file build off the word
list IST nvd National vulnerability
database it's great I don't like it I'll
tell you why in a moment and then of
course you have the system known
vulnerabilities and exposures catalog is
there anybody in here that works for uh
like state state level government
or does any Contracting for state level
government
all right so the cisa known
vulnerabilities exposures catalog you
have to follow that everything you do
has to follow this uh as of a document
that came out uh two years ago and I'll
show you that as well
so the Verizon DVI curse sat in a
nutshell it's from 2008 to present day
it has private and public Awards and it
uses the vocabulary vocabulary for event
recording and incident sharing and
that's how many incidences they've
recorded so far and that's a big bat
that's this year by the way that's this
report from this year and I can show you
a little bit of the companies that are
involved in this
so out of this these are the companies
that contribute so it's a very large
data set
private private and public country
companies and this is one of my
favorites I always use the sets from
this in order to present what's going on
threat model in order to build a threat
model and the Finnegans
you know like air gapping your
environments
and I wanted to show this to y'all
because I think things are getting a
little better
we can improve and this this is going to
fall on you all in the audience
so this is over time since it first
started 2017. the great thing is you see
social engineering's gone down right
that's a great Trend that means we're
training we're not opening emails we're
not supposed to open we're at clicking
links we're not supposed to click the
problem I see you see the basic web
application attacks that's your
cross-site scripting that's your I
literally go to a website run a few curl
commands and a few put commands and I
can get past your web application
so be real careful whenever you're
making your shiny apps and stuff and
maybe even have a pen test or go through
and run some checks on it there's a lot
of there's a trend on that because more
and more of our lives are going from a
you know the tangible you're holding it
in your hand or taking a report to your
boss's office to creating a web app that
people log in to look at and so because
of that there's more code out there the
code has to get out there faster we've
got a rising Trend and I actually have
some zero days for that right now on my
laptop but I'm not going to share those
with you I'm sorry
so like I said the meter cdes
it's a blue jean blue team's favorites
it's on files
loaded and vulnerability scanners nicely
uh that's how many CDs as of that date
that you see up there the 27th that's
how many were total recorded these are
all submitted from bug bounties like
just individual hackers that put stuff
together it looks amazing on your resume
if you're a hacker and you have actually
done a published CBE
the thing is I wanted to present this to
you all because if you have uh if you're
going through the CVS the meter cves a
lot of these are used in hacking
competitions whenever we go to a
conference the CTS consists of multiple
cves so that we've got the code out
there we tell people how to hack it and
it's all there and people are practicing
on these and these are supposed to be
low hanging fruit as long as you can
take care of these in a timely manner
you're going to be good I can't I will
never say 100 not hack because people
are clever
no this is the one I don't like there's
a reason why I don't like this I used to
work for the dod as an aircraft mechanic
and then I became a system admin for
about three years and uh I wrote a lot
of scripts because I'm a lazy coder so I
wrote scripts to do my job for me they
kicked out products I followed those
products I was able to do everything
follow-up problem is nist doesn't say
well here's the change coming here's the
change what do you think of the change
and then they go here's the new change
enjoy so I had to rewrite my scripts
every month
so yeah I'm not a fan but this is a very
strong Model A lot of government models
use this they just take the uh they take
the database they build up the defense
for it and actually disable Services
according to this list
all right so this one I really wanted to
present to you guys especially working
in state or if you're doing State
contracts so this is the Baseline the
known vulnerability exposures uh it was
established by The Binding operational
director of 1902. not 1902 but you're
19-02. so the reason why that was there
was the government said well we've got a
lot of contractors that have
vulnerabilities we need to set us a
Baseline and they did the Baseline
literally sets it up to where
if you do not fix these cves and they're
found in your environment after that
date you can no longer be a contractor
so I wanted to show you guys this
because this is live this is what it
looks like right now we've got a drop
down date of the 19th of this month for
multiple cdes
so if you have this stuff in your
environment you just have a cyber
security person look at these and they
can actually go through and run a scan
against it or they could manually do it
but if these aren't taken care of you
can't be in the contract and you have to
do the change management and work
everything through for that as well
it got quiet I gave you bad news didn't
I
foreign
so yeah that's the drop dead date so
this is the one I'm gonna do my best not
to victim blame it's very hard not to do
when it comes to cyber security we see
uh hospitals and we see everybody else
getting taken and then they pay off the
bounties on the stuff not the Bounty
sorry they pay off the ransoms and it
just makes things worse because once
that goes public you've got more and
more hackers going into it I try not to
victim blame but we always try to say
have better practices do better you can
do better just like it happened uh I
think it was seven years ago where we
were one of the major credit companies
got hacked that was a misconfigured
Apache web server anybody could have
found it it doesn't take a skid I mean a
skid could have found it easily and I
think that's who did find it and exploit
and put it all out there
um it's it's very important to try to
put it that way and I understand that
companies have to make money but they're
starting to push more and more into
danger zone
so the uh
so and the other thing that I've seen
lately is with the features and services
behind a paywall
um a lot of people think Farmers aren't
too smart but once they started making
them pay monthly bills to unlock
features on their tractors they learned
how to hack
they learn how to program I met a few of
them at a Midwest Wild West hacking Fest
and they they basically went around and
broke everybody's tractors because John
Deere was charging them monthly for it
and now Mercedes is trying to do the
same thing BMW does it Intel is starting
to do it on their servers and I'm like
yeah you're screwed you're going to get
hacked after a week it's not going to
take any time for somebody to unlock
that stuff
I also want to go into the responsible
disclosure as a thing and this is what
I'm talking about with the bug bounties
I've mentioned a few of you one-on-one I
do talk about this probably too much
because I get excited about this stuff
so bug bounties is basically I'm a
hacker I'm at home I find a
vulnerability on the website I do a
write-up on what I found I send you the
bug bounty
um
five years ago people made a lot of
money people could make a living off of
it there were hackers that were
literally just living day to day and
they did it they did a great job
I have a friend of mine that you can
follow his links and this is a
responsible responsible disclosure day
because he has already submitted these
bug bounties over 180 days ago and then
none of them were approved he's got
denial letter after denial letter and
they all proof of concept work so I'm
seeing this trend with a lot of my other
hacker friends where they're not getting
paid and so when you take a lot of
people that are on that edge of being an
ethical hacker and going you know if I
was unethical I could be a lot richer
and then now the companies are saying
now we're not going to give you that
money we're not going to pay you
so I'm just giving you all the warning
to you know keep an eye on your stuff I
think things are going to get a little
bit worse
Doom Gloom sorry
so this is what I'm saying with the
responsible disclosure companies aren't
paying bugs and they're they're not
giving out resources to support ethical
hackers anymore we do have a few
websites those websites I'm not going to
call them out by name they have also not
been standing in the gap for a lot of
the hackers and so that's for me those
are my friends it sucks because a lot of
them uh they just can't make day-to-day
work they're trying to find out the
means of working talented people but
they're not getting paid for the bug
bounties and the companies that they're
supposed to representing they're
supposed to be representing them are not
doing that anymore
so uh I also put a link up there by a
reputable hacker this is the guy uh that
I asked hey can I release these today
has enough time lapse he said that's
fine and that's what that link is that
says GitHub there's a lot of zero days
there
it's a lot of nastiness I'm not going to
run any dmos on it because I don't want
to break anybody's stuff
so the other issue is iot is fast and
cheap
so when you have the internet of things
I like to call it iOS for certain
reasons you can add Internet of yep
there's a reason for that it's because
people have to release these things as
fast as they can to beat their
competitor and the problem is you have i
o boards left open you have them
Hardware wired to not change passwords
you can't change the passwords and I'm
put up there the exposed Port 515 and
9100 because there's a tool called pret
and these are those are printer ports
and there's a lot of iot devices that
have exposed printer ports and
and uh I was gonna do a scan to show you
but it just took too long and there was
just so many I did a random scan within
map which is perfectly legal by the way
you can run a passive scan to see what
open ports there are on the internet and
the list got too long for me to actually
present and Export it to a file so
that's how many devices are out there
with that open port and with the Pratt
you can actually you can actually uh
leverage that vulnerability in your
advantage
so toys to break the world
these are some of my favorite toys
um they're not the only ones and they're
pretty cool you got the USB rubber ducky
The Flipper zero
this thing the hack RF the Wi-Fi
pineapple and the new one which is the
shadina this is software that came out
23 days ago and I'll go over that
running out of time love it so the USB
rubber ducky looks like a duck it quacks
like a duck it must be a duck what this
is the small computer on a USB stick and
what it does is it tells your computer
hey I'm a I'm a
it says I am a keyboard
and then you run a script and it runs
scripts as if you're typing on a
keyboard
so you can imagine what that does it
doesn't matter if you have antivirus it
doesn't matter if you have anything else
running it's as if somebody's sitting on
your keyboard typing so somebody walks
by plugs this in I'm actually going to
do a demo for you real quick because
they have it on the flipper zero they
actually have the software there
the way it works
is I can just set it up to run a rubber
ducky script
I can see
and I plug it in
and it's going to think my Cube computer
is going to think it's a keyboard
and it's just going to run it
or it's supposed to
see this is why I don't like Demo World
myself
that's all right it probably is trying
to run it on my Linux machine yeah it is
because like I said I had other demos
for you
try it again
yeah there it goes so this is what you
see what it's doing it just it's running
like a keyboard if somebody's typing
this can do it via USB and then also do
it via Bluetooth so I can connect your
laptop and run some exploits maybe to
set up a web server on your computer
grab your files if I want to
runs pretty quick you can also make it
to where it doesn't show anything this
is a demo so obviously
we're seeing it but normally we wouldn't
see what's going on
I'm fighting the clock here I'm laughing
at myself
now you ever add more to a thing
thinking you don't have enough time that
you don't feel enough okay so that's the
flipper zero hack RS this is an RF
receiver device it works with software
to find radio
um you can receive everything one thing
that I do at home is I like to receive
iff transponder signals from aircraft
and I can track them because as they fly
over I'm an aircraft guy so I like to
watch that you can also pick up uh pager
traffic from Emergency Services because
that's not encrypted it's just encoded
so you just plug in and encode and you
can read all the pager traffic you know
how many passwords go across that it's
pretty insane and they're like how do I
get into this oh this is the password so
you know be careful what you're what
you're sending out what you're doing
with that
uh the Wi-Fi pineapple is a Wi-Fi device
I was going to do a demo but I don't
have time your phone is constantly
sending out beacons and probes now with
the Wi-Fi pineapple so uh you know it
sends out a beacon going well my home am
I at home and this goes yeah you're at
home connect to me
so me as a hacker if I'm in the middle
of that and you connect to me I now can
perform men in the middle attacks like
give you a fake Google login or whatever
now I've got your credentials when you
log in so one thing I could tell people
in public today turn your Wi-Fi off when
you're not using it or I know there's
other ways you can set it up to where
it'll only turn on Wi-Fi when you're at
certain geographical locations I'm
pretty sure Jared turned off his Wi-Fi
because he was afraid I was going to do
something while I was up here
and this is the new one this is I just
learned about this I'm gonna try to be
quick on the shenan is the automated
host exploitation framework the mission
of the project is to fully automate the
scanning vulnerability scanning analysis
the exploitation using artificial
intelligence
it's integrated with Metasploit and nmap
for pointing the attacks as well as
being integrated in-house command and
control server for exfiltration of data
from the environment now with shadina
you just run the code point it at a
server and if any of those cdes public
cves are open it'll automatically
exploit this is a skinny tool came out
23 days 23 days ago as a proof of
concept uh right now it's it's it's a
dangerous piece of kit
all right so I'm going to skip ahead
because where I am corrective actions I
tell people to Silo their personal
identity use different email addresses
one for your financial one for your
paying your home stuff one for your
social media accounts and then like one
for your work and then another one for
your family one of those gets exploits
you only lose that part of your life and
you don't have to correct everything
else keep your crypto in your freezer
those of you that have crypto coins keep
them on a log X not connect to the
internet but I wanna like you can put
them on a USB stick you can put them on
a freezer they have different locks to
do that keep them cold
keep stuff on your own Hardware if you
can I know that's not always possible
but one thing I have at home is instead
of buying a ring doorbell I built one
that whenever somebody comes by it sends
me an email when somebody goes by the
door because I don't want somebody else
to have that data I want to keep that
data cost me 35 95 with all the hardware
that I had to build it with using a
Raspberry Pi I use a password manager I
have a sticker on here that says my
passwords got hacked I had to change the
name of my dog don't do that
so Rita is a threat intelligent threat
and that this is what I wanted you all
to see and I wish I'd gotten to it and
talk about it but it uses uh your type
of math to figure out what a hack looks
like in a live Beacon environment and I
put the links on my slide because right
now it's getting contributed with a
bunch of hackers but I think some data
analytics people can really contribute
to this project and help out
um it's been around for about two years
it's named after John strand's mom and
it was introduced from Black Hills
information security and it's it's
always going to be open source and
available it's written and go so that's
it